joe biden yesterday he's just a guy full
of good news you can remember before
you know we had the first day of spring
this uh this
this week
and so winter is officially over
and we remember we go back to whatever
whatever it was november december joe
biden promised us a winter of death and
sickness and despair
and didn't seem to be that for me i mean
you know it seems like um
the winter wasn't too bad but he
promised it would be a winter of death
and winter of death didn't exactly work
out
but now
maybe we'll have a spring of death
because he says that food shortages
are on the horizon listen
with regard to food shortage yes we did
we
still talk about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real the the
price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries in our country as
well
and uh because both uh russia and
ukraine have been the bread basket of
europe in terms of wheat for example
just give one example
but we had a long discussion uh in the
g7
with uh um
the uh
with both
the united states which has a
significant the third largest producer
of wheat in the world
as well as canada which is also a major
major producer
and we both talked about how we could
increase and disseminate more rapidly
food shortages in addition to that we
talked about
uh urging all the european countries and
everyone else to
end trade
restrictions on
on sending
limitations on sending food abroad
and so we are in the process of working
out with our european friends
what it would be what it would take to
help alleviate the concerns relative to
food shortages we also talked about a
significant major u.s investment among
others in terms of providing for
the need for
humanitarian assistance including food
as we move forward
so what exactly happened to build back
better i think we've moved on from that
i guess no more no more building back
better
now we have winters of death
winter of death going into a spring of
despair
food shortages now he says food
shortages are coming
last i checked they've already kind of
been here
and so that's that's part of what is is
happening here why joe biden's going
around talking about food shortages
um
promising that things are going to get
so much worse and we've heard a lot i've
never heard i i can't remember ever
hearing
this much
pessimism from a politician who's in
charge of things now it's one thing when
you're
running against an incumbent
and then you're pessimistic about the
way things are going right now and you
say well elect me and things will be
better
but for the guy who's actually in charge
who's this pessimistic about by the way
things are heading
part of the reason for that of course is
now he's trying to pin everything on on
putin
and so he's saying oh food shortages are
coming because of you know the war in
russia and putin and he's doing all this
well as i said last i checked
that was already a problem i mean joe
biden i think fairly was getting labeled
bare shelves biden
before the war in ukraine
you know you could go uh on
social media and find the pictures of
bare shells grocery stores going back
months before any of this happened helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for somebody else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way that you sleep individually
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling down whatever you need
mattresses great for spinal alignment to
prevent morning aches and pains if
you're getting old like me and even a
helix plus mattress for plus sized
sleepers
so
if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to and the mattress
comes right to your door shipped for
free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again
which is great especially if you're a
plus size sleeper you can
don't need to get as much exercise just
go to helixsleep.com walsh take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but uh i guarantee you
will helix even has financing options
and flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com
walsh
so this is a this has been a great
opportunity for biden to take all of
these things that were already happening
gas prices inflation food shortages uh
supply chain issues all that stuff
all that was already happening was
already trending in this direction and
take it all and just put it in the lap
of putin
that's why that's why i you know by
administration very grateful in fact
what's happening in ukraine right now
because it gives them an opportunity to
blame all of their own failures on putin
all these things are already happening
now is
putin's invasion of ukraine is that
helping any of these issues is it
helping gas prices no
is it contributing to some of the
problems sure
but none of these things began a few
weeks ago when putin invaded ukraine
we were already heading in that
direction
and um
and now he wants of course pinot nolan
putin
you also get the sense
here's the most disturbing thing for me
every time i i
see joe biden and i listen to him and
he's talking about these problems
um
you get the sense well first of all of
course that he's just confused and he
doesn't know exactly what's going on
because he does have dementia and we
have a president with dementia
um that's what happens when you decide
that an 80 year old needs to be
president
but you also get the sense that he
doesn't
he doesn't seem to care that much
about any problems there's no real
there's no real sense of urgency at all
from this guy
that's why when all hell's breaking
loose he'll just go off to delaware and
you know take a five-day weekend
that's why he still he still go to bed
at 7 30
um even the midst of
crisis after crisis
some of that is
again the fact that he is physically
mentally collapsing
but it's also i think a lack of urgency
a lack of concern
and that goes back to his own moral
failings but also that also could be
traced back to his age
you know that i i hate to always have to
tie everything back to this and harp on
this point but it's an important point
and i think we need to keep it front of
mind here
that yeah even if joe even if this was
if joe biden was 20 years younger we'd
still be having a lot of the same
problems
because he still he still would be
incompetent
but um
this is only making all those problems
even worse
the fact that he's so old
and i think it contributes to a lack of
urgency and a lack of concern because
uh well frankly
he's not gonna be around
for very long because he's old
so i don't think he's sitting around
really worried about long-term solutions
this is not going to be his problem for
very long
yet another reason why we need younger
people in office and not just in the
white house i mean in office running the
country
we need younger people
so that they're more physically and
mentally equipped but also so that they
have a stake in the future so they're
going to be around
to deal with the consequences of
whatever decisions they make
and their kids are going to be around
and they're going to be around also to
see their kids dealing with those
consequences
it always makes me nervous even more
nervous when i when i consider the fact
that so many of the people at the
highest levels of government making the
most important decisions
are not going to be around to see the
consequences of any of these decisions
i think that should make us all very
nervous
you know you have a president who's in
his you know 40s 50s even 60s like he's
got
several decades left probably on earth
you never know for sure no one knows
when they're when they're leaving but um
these are people who have decades left
and they're gonna be around
um
and
that's it it's all inevitable the
consequence of
going into a nursing home and finding
the most geriatric people and saying hey
you want to run the country
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated